chip Reid who is on Capitol Hill where
senators will make the first moves in
their impeachment trial later today chip
what do we expect to see today well for
the what we're really expecting is
organized chaos as the Republicans and
Democrats debate exactly how this
impeachment trial will proceed Mitch
McConnell wants to speed it through as
quickly as possible and Democrats are
livid so now for the third time in
American history the fate of the
president is in the hands of just 100
senators leader McConnell is going along
with president Trump's coverup hook line
and sinker
Democrats blasted Republican leader
Mitch McConnell's proposed rules for the
president's impeachment trial which say
none of the evidence collected in the
House impeachment inquiry will be
admitted automatically the Senate will
have to vote to enter it that's a
significant departure from the Clinton
impeachment process which McConnell has
said he is following what's good for
President Clinton is good for President
Trump it tries to speed this through in
the dead of night the proposal also lays
out that each side will have 24 hours
over two days for opening arguments that
will be followed by 16 hours of
questioning by senators only then can
they debate and vote on whether to have
witnesses McConnell is hell-bent on
making it much more difficult to get
witnesses and documents and intent on
rushing the trial through Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer has
already vowed to introduce amendments we
will fight that tooth and nail Democrats
insist on hearing from additional
witnesses including former national
security adviser John Bolton who has
said he's willing to testify Donald
Trump has done nothing wrong many Senate
Republicans don't want to prolong the
trial we do not want to do anything that
is going to weaken executive privilege
we do not want anything that is going to
embolden the house but Democrats are
hoping for Republicans will cross party
lines and vote for new witnesses we hope
that for brave Republicans will resist
McConnell's cover-up the White House
announced Monday that Ohio's Jim Jordan
and
other loyal House Republicans will be
joining the president's impeachment team
they will act as surrogates defending
the president in the court of public
opinion
Democrats have never accepted the will
of the American people Democrats have
been quick to point out that the White
House is not challenging that basic
claim that President Trump pressured
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's and
in the rebuttal the Democrats said the
president is the founding fathers worst
nightmare come to life Gail thank you
very much chip
you